call of duty modern warfare season two
kicks off on February 11th bringing new
multiplayer maps modes weapons and a
battle pass to the game let's jump right
into all the new stuff day 1 brings us
to standard multiplayer maps one of them
is Atlas Super Store a warehouse that's
been taken over by Al khatallah letting
you battle down the aisles over fallen
shelves and even in some special areas
in the back meanwhile modern warfare
twos rust has returned bringing back
some of the most intense close quarters
action the series has ever had rust can
also be used as a gunfight map the same
goes for the new map Bazaar said an ER
6th and additionally day one brings a
new ground war map it's an airplane
junkyard called Zhukov boneyard lastly
there's another new map called candor
hideout coming later in season 2 but
Infinity Ward hasn't released any
information about that yet gunfight
tournaments will be available with
season 2 but only for a limited time
there's also a co D League rule set
playlist for those of you who want to
play like a pros more game modes are
coming later this season demolition will
return alongside the new infected ground
war in that mode you'll have to fight
off the infected until time expires but
if you get infected yourself you'll join
the Horde as they attempt to kill off
the remaining survivors finally there's
nvg reinforced which Infinity Ward says
quote blends elements of domination with
Search and Destroy now let's talk about
new weapons and that battle pass if you
don't want to spend any money
you can still unlock some new guns the
growl 556 is unlocked it - you're 15 and
the striker 45 is unlocked at - you're
31 you can get both for free there's
also a third new weapon coming later in
season 2 but Infinity Ward has marked it
as classified for now for 1,000 Call of
Duty points or about ten US dollars you
can purchase the pass and the ability to
unlock all 100 tiers of rewards the tier
0 prize is actually a new operator
modern warfare twos ghost the British
spec ops officer is linked to the story
of season 2 and he's not the only new
operator joining the ranks Talon and
mace will also deploy later this season
as far as ranking up in the battle path
season two offers a bunch of new trials
including ATV races a gun course a
live-fire exercise and pitcher which is
basically cornhole but with frag
grenades new daily challenges and
missions will be ready for completion
too that's all the big stuff coming with
season 2 On February 11th there are new
maps to explore and new guns to handle
with more coming later this season stay
tuned to game spot for all the best
modern warfare coverage and we'll see
you out there
[Applause]
you